peu
dont des voiles à savoir ce qu'ils
travaillent bien comme ça oui
[Musique]
lassé du groupe
alors pour défaire tout seul tu fais ça
qu'il faut déjà une expérience de france
inter il ya quatre ou cinq ans mais
c'était dans le sud de la france dans
les dents l'aviron et on était descendu
dans un âge jeune j'ai plus comment il
s'appelait j'avais bien aimé sais pas
c'est pas mon mieux je préfère mais
c'est sans doute par défaut de
connaissance
mais les intellectuels de l'image mais
ses preuves
si on remonte pas tu ramènes l'hélico
mais toi tu l'accompagna les pouilles tu
seras plus souple tu le pilote est tu
prends tout quand il quand ils
descendent dans le trou pas droit à
l'erreur parce que c'est un peu une
course contre la montre il faut
respecter les horaires mais c'est
beaucoup moins difficile à filmer qu'une
véritable expédition souterraines
voilà
et après donc pour des 130 ans a tout de
suite ses danses
[Musique]